the method that we're looking for for
distance based phylogeny construction is
called the neighbor-joining algorithm
which was introduced in 1987 it's a
result so fundamental to bioinformatics
in fact that it has been cited 30,000
times and it's one of the top 20 most
cited papers overall scientific fields
so first to see how this works
define the neighbor-joining matrix of a
given distance matrix D as the matrix D
star whose IJ entry is given by the
formula shown on the slide so let me
give you an example here's the matrix
that we encountered before where J and K
correspond to the minimum element of the
matrix but J and K were not neighbors in
the tree that fit this matrix the total
distance of a leaf node is just the sum
of distances from this leaf to all other
leaves so for example the total distance
of K in this matrix is 21 plus 12 plus
13 or 46 we will then define D star of
IJ by taking n minus 2 times D of IJ and
then subtracting the total distance of I
and subtracting the total distance of J
in this case n the number of leaves or
the number of rows and our distance
matrix is equal to 4 so D star of say KL
is equal to 2 times D of KL which is 13
minus 46 minus 48 which gives us a value
of negative 68 for D star of KL now if
it's obvious to you that defining this
crazy matrix D star was going to be a
productive endeavor then you are
probably far smarter than I am
like the burrows-wheeler transform which
we encounter in another chapter and
which makes matching multiple patterns
to a text a lightning-fast endeavor
I think this matrix D star is black
magic whereas taking a minimum element
of the original distance matrix did not
guarantee that we were going to find
neighbors taking a minimum element of
the neighbor-joining matrix D star does
find a pair of neighbor
so you can find a proof of this theorem
in a detour in the text it's not a short
proof in fact although d-star was
introduced in 1987 it took a decade
before proof of this theorem was found
also the neighbor-joining theorem is
part of the reason why I led you down
the wrong path in the first place when
we first attempted to construct a
phylogeny from a distance matrix now if
we use D star instead of D then we will
be able to successfully identify a pair
of neighbors from a minimum element of
the matrix so let's walk through the
neighbor joining algorithm first we can
strike the matrix D star and I'll move
that up from the previous slide so there
are two pairs of leaves that correspond
to a minimum element of D star I and J
must be neighbors and K and L must be
neighbors as well let's work with say I
and J we set Delta sub IJ equal to the
total distance of I minus the total
distance of J all divided by n minus 2
so here when we plug those values in we
see that Delta sub IJ is going to be
equal to 9 now you may remember before
that we had a formula for the limb
length of I the formula that
neighbor-joining uses is going to give
the same result when the underlying
distance matrix D is additive but this
formula offers better results when we
deal with non-additive distance matrices
so that's why this formula differs from
the one that we had before here limb
length of I is equal to one-half of the
original distance matrix value D IJ plus
Delta sub IJ and limb length of J is
equal to 1/2 D IJ minus Delta IJ so now
that we have these limb lengths we can
remove the I throw and the J throw as
long as as well as the ice column and
the J column from D and then add a row
that corresponds to the parent node of I
and J or M and then we denote this
matric this smaller matrix as D Prime
for each other leaf k we then compute
the distance between K and this parent
node M as the distance from Ida k plus
the distance from J to K minus the
distance from I to J all divided by 2
does this formula look familiar
I hope so it's the same formula that we
derived several sections ago when we
first attempted to reconstruct a tree
from an additive matrix so if we return
to neighbor-joining now that we have a
smaller matrix we can apply the
neighbor-joining algorithm recursively
to D Prime and obtain the tree on the
right that fits this matrix D Prime once
we have this tree we can simply reattach
the limbs of I and J using the limb
links that we previously computed so
here's the summary of the
neighbor-joining algorithm which we
apply recursively until we obtain a 2 by
2 distance matrix when we form an edge
and then we retrace our steps by adding
limbs successively go ahead try
implementing it yourself in particular
see what happens when the
neighbor-joining algorithm is given a
non-additive matrix because we know
what's going to happen when it's given
an additive matrix the tree constructed
by upgma on this same non-additive
matrix is shown on the right how does
the tree that you create by running the
neighbor-joining algorithm differ from
this upgma tree of course we can also
apply neighbor-joining to the non
additive distance matrix that we derived
from coronaviruses but we can also apply
it to a distance matrix that we obtain
from pairwise alignment of sprite spike
proteins taken from different patients
as well as from the Palm Civet
coronavirus when we do this just from
this small sample of 10 coronaviruses we
can see a very clear pattern of how the
disease was passed from the Palm Civet
to residents in southern China at the
end of 2002 and then how it spread to
other other residents throughout the
beginning
early 2003 and then we see the cases
from the Metropole Hotel grouping
together as the disease went global it
probably seems like we've come a long
way in our discussion of distance based
approaches for constructing evolutionary
trees but we should point out that these
algorithms don't allow us to infer
anything about the ancestors that are
assigned to the internal nodes of the
tree the reason why we can't infer
anything is because when we pass from a
multiple alignment to a distance matrix
we inherently lost information about the
sequences themselves in order to say
anything about ancestral States we're
going to need an approach that can
analyze the alignment directly